let's focus on the three racist things  Trump's been up to lately starting with  this President Trump Unapologetic  defending his racist Twitter tirade  aimed at four Democratic congresswomen  of color after telling them Sunday to go  back to help fix the totally broken and  crime-infested places from which they  came sadly the only thing that should  surprise anyone is that  it ending a sentence with a preposition  spear now return your head to the  orifice from which it came  of course it wasn't long before I'm  trying the this is this is not a bit at  this point I want to laugh at a Samantha  Bee joke I do that is on my bucket list  some people want to climb Mount Everest  I I want to find I want to find a funny  Samantha Bee joke that's all I want to  do with my life now